c'est drôle la vie pour moi c'est fou
d'être aujourd'hui devant vous ici aux
tadjiks
je me rappelle très bien un peu plus
jeune j'avais l'habitude de venir
régulièrement ici à bordeaux avec mon
papa
car à l'époque c'était impossible pour
nous trouver des grandes tailles de
basket à pau donc on monte dans son
grand camion blanc c'était un renault
trafic pour ceux qui connaissent et là
on voulait pendant trois heures jusqu'à
arriver à un magasin de sport non loin
d'ici sur la route on parlait ont refusé
le monde je posais des questions
mon papa
c'était un idéaliste un rêveur ils
avaient pour eux
l'injustice et les inégalités
il rêvait d'être un acteur du changement
de créer le changement
et puis un jour il a perdu son rêve il a
perdu espoir
une belle matinée d'été et c'est quitter
la vie je suppose que la froideur de
notre société
li a poussé
einstein a dit la n tout comme le froid
ou l'obscurité n'existe pas seules
existent
le manque de chaleur le manque de
lumière et le manque d'amour lorsque
cela arrive en fait c'est à ce moment là
qu'on laisse les peurs nous envahir que
l'on crée des murs et que l'on se
renferme sur nous mêmes et c'est un peu
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en france
n'est ce pas vous l'avez peut-être
remarqué mais il semble que la culture
de la méfiance de la peur prend de plus
en plus le dessus
il semble aussi que l'obscurité devient
de plus en plus une force dominante
alors que pouvons nous faire contre ça
entre cette obscurité
aujourd'hui elle se rend compte que dans
une société il nous faut être de plus en
plus créatifs
il nous faut trouver de meilleures
solutions chaque jour dans ce système
froid moi je l' ai ressenti vraiment
très fort le jour où au conseil de
classe
le proviseur a décrété que de toute
façon mes absences la baisse de mes
notes n'étaient pas justifiées parce que
de toute façon nous avions tous des
problèmes alors là on vous commencez à
sentir la rage qui monte la colère
moi ce qui m'a sauvée en fait c'est le
fait que grâce au sport j'ai eu
l'opportunité de pouvoir partir de
pouvoir quitter cet environnement quand
j'y pense bien
beaucoup des gosses de mon quartier
n'ont pas eu cette chance
certains sont tombés en prison dans la
drogue ou autre maman me disait
récemment que au cameroun
l'école c'est un échappatoire qui permet
de s'échapper de la réalité de la vie
qui permet aussi de se ré imaginer et en
fait j'aime beaucoup ce concept de
imaginer un nouveau futur imaginé une
nouvelle vie survey ré-imaginer soi même
c'est ça qui me passionne en fait c'est
ça qui me fait vivre et susciter des
vocations aider des jeunes à devenir
qu'ils sont en 2015
l'année dernière l'évènement marquant ça
a été les attentats de paris
alors on a vu notre nation s'unir et
marcher ensemble pleuré ensemble on
était tous au diapason sur le son
je suis paris je suis charlie en gros le
message c'était nous sommes tous unis
nous sommes tous victimes en classe dans
ce que j'appelle mon laboratoire
je demande à mes élèves de retourner les
problèmes d'aller vraiment chercher les
causes les symptômes et les conséquences
lorsque j'ai pris du relief de la
hauteur en fait j'ai réalisé que et si
au fond on n'était pas tous coupables
coupables d'avoir laissé la froideur
s'installer dans notre société coupable
de ne pas se dire bonjour de pas
connaître nos voisins on est aussi
coupable de participer à un système
matérialiste où les courbes de
croissance sont bien plus importantes
bien plus en bien plus de valeur que le
bien-être
donc cette culpabilité
quels sont les faits alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de négatif
mais il n'ya pas que de l'obscurité
il ya aussi du positif
il ya aussi de la lumière aujourd'hui on
a une génération de jeunes qui est prête
à mourir pour une cause aussi mauvaise
cette cause soit elle et je me dis que
peut-être c'est peut-être symptomatique
d'une génération qui a une telle quête
de sens une telle une énorme envie de
devenir les héros qu'au fond on est
peut-être aussi coupables nous de ne pas
leur permettre de devenir des héros de
ne pas leur permettre de devenir les
héros de leur vie
ça passe par quoi devenir les héros de
sa vie alors comment on apprend à des
jeunes à des enfants à devenir des héros
d'un premièrement il faut que l'on
construise une ingénierie de l'audace du
rêve de l'espoir je pense qu'on doit pas
planter des graines de héros et les
arroser d'espoir tous les jours petit à
petit
créé cet écosystème aujourd'hui si on
veut apprendre comment on va le faire
c'est très siens je vais vous demander
de fermer vos yeux de déployer vauzelle
et puis là on va se laisser s'envoler
on va monter on atteint déjà le ciel on
continue à monter on va dépasser
l'atmosphère on est dans la stratosphère
on continue
puis là on a la tête dans les étoiles
ouvrez vos yeux
est-ce qu'il y en a parmi vous qui ont
déjà vu star wars ce qu'ils peuvent
lever la main ah oui effectivement
j'aurais dû poser la question qui dans
cette salle n'a pas vu star wars rien à
moins alors dans star wars il ya un
personnage qui s'appelle anakin
skywalker alors anakin c'est un gitaï
c'est à dire un jeune soldat qui est
destiné à devenir un héros de par son
passé son enfance
anakin il est plein de peur il manque de
confiance en lui de peau de par son
histoire
si on fait un parallèle on pensa à mehdi
coulibaly un des auteurs des attentats
de paris et on se rencontre aussi
c'était quelqu'un qui était plein de
peur je vais revenir après dessus donc
je disais que anakin d'un skywalker et
plein de peur et à un jour il décide de
par sa raison qu'il voulait vraiment il
avait une grande quête de devenir un
héros de trouver un sens à sa vie il
décide de prendre des décisions
radicales et il tombe dans ce qu'on
appelle le côté obscur et il devient
dark vador
si on construit pas un terreau fertile
pour des jeunes on les perd je reviens
sur un mehdi coulibaly un des auteurs
des attentats de paris l'année dernière
lorsqu'on regarde c'est ans d'histoire
on se rend compte que deux ans avant de
commettre des attentats il était passé
sur une chaîne du grand public et il
dénonçait en fait les mauvaises
conditions des prisonniers des détenus
dans les prisons françaises un peu avant
il avait rencontré le président avec un
jeune de deux des jeunes des
associations des jeunes activistes
français
quelque part il y avait une quête de
devenir un héros qui n'a pas été
satisfaites
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait comment
aujourd'hui on transforme et comment on
apprend à ces jeunes à devenir des héros
c'est très simple on va partir de la
définition même de ce que c'est qu'un
héros aéro c'est une personne courageuse
qui commet un acte avec abnégation
donc en fait on va moi ce que je vous
propose de faire c'est de créer des
écoles où on va avoir
on va enseigner aux enfants avoir une
pensée héroïque on va semer cette graine
du héros dans ces écoles on va aussi
apprendre aux enfants à ne pas avoir
peur à ne pas se laisser dominer par la
peur à la gérer et aussi on va leur
apprendre à ne pas avoir peur de l'échec
à savoir qu en fait l'échec
c'est une grande source d'apprendre
d'apprentissage de plus dans ces écoles
on va créer un nouveau paradigme est en
fait dans ce paradis cno là on va
mélanger les concepts de apprentissage
avec les concepts de désapprentissage
ses enfants qui seront dans cette école
on va leur apprendre à avoir une vision
à voir plus loin à imaginer un autre
demain à imaginer un autre monde
moi personnellement j'ai la conviction
qu'il existe en chacun de nous un jedi
qui sommeille et je voudrais vous
demander une dernière petite chose s'il
y en a dans cette salle qui pensent
qu'ils peuvent devenir des jedi des
héros ou qui pensent qu'ils le sont déjà
je vous demande de vous lever s'il vous
plaît
merci